what's the use of Gossip one reason that
it's advantageous is that it's not
physical attack the reason that women
don't engage in physical aggression is
mystery women were more often caregiving
for dependent Offspring and so what that
meant is that if you die your child is
more likely to die and indeed across
cultures and throughout history children
are more likely to die if their mother
is not around compared to if their
father's not around and so when women
risk physical violence when they risk
injury or death they are risking those
things for their children as well gossip
is indirect and one of the reasons it's
great is because you can deny
culpability you can spread this
information without it necessarily being
cleared that you were the one that
spread it that's important to prevent
retaliation either in the form of
physical violence or reputational
violence